it's great seeing you sir how are you
doing
oh it's great seeing you i'm doing great
i'm uh i'm up i'm in upstate new york uh
making a show
uh i know i know what you're making
right now i'm very excited oh good good
i don't know it's a wild uh
journey that we're on over here but uh i
i think we're making something good
yeah i heard the scripts are very good
um
i'll talk to you about that later
because i totally have questions for
venom so i want to know if when you
found out you were going to make the
sequel was the first thing you did was
burn the wig from the first film
[Laughter]
well
i didn't like that wig uh i i wasn't
dazzled by that wig uh
so yeah i definitely wanted
a different wig
so
the character cletus is very popular
with fans and i'm curious when you were
getting ready to really dive in for this
film did you look at anything to inspire
how he was gonna sound and maybe his
mannerisms knowing that he has like a
pretty big fan base with marble fans
well i mean if i had thought about him
having a big fan base with marble fans
that would have been difficult for me i
i tried to just approach it like i would
any other character although being in
the marvel universe is
it's not going to be just any other
thing but uh
uh
you know you know i i felt it was good
looking at the old comics and stuff and
trying to get a sense of uh
what kind of
nasty [ __ ] happened in his childhood
that influenced him to become this
deranged
you know serial killer uh
that that was helpful
uh i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of movies you
know that about me what do you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of venom two
well
uh from my vantage point you know i did
vintage
venom one because of reuben fleischer
and who i you know love and i just well
also because it's marvel and because i
think tom hardy's phenomenal actor but
i just assume reuben will be at the helm
on the second one so we're going to be
safe
you know
it'll be good too
and uh sure enough he didn't do it but
uh
the the thing you might not know is that
there was a period where there was some
names uh bandied about and tom and i
both tom hardy and i uh you know really
lobbied tom rothman to
to use andy and and i think probably tom
rothman today is
pretty glad he made that choice
um i am listen i think you're a very
talented actor and i love learning about
um how actors like to work i'm just
curious if you have like a really
emotional or dramatic scene and say
you're filming that on a monday how do
you typically like to get ready to do
something like that are you doing it
days in advance where you're breaking it
down are you thinking about is it more
like the day before where you start
getting in your head do you do you get
nervous the night before are you not
sleeping can you sort of talk about that
well that's interesting because here we
are on a saturday and on monday i'll be
filming a very dramatic scene
uh with justin thoreau in this uh who's
playing gordon liddy and so
uh
you know
i'm gonna find that out in the next
in the next day and a half what all
kinds of emotions go through my head but
i try to be as prepared as possible and
to have the the preparation meet
spontaneity
and you know hopefully some good
chemistry develop in the in the scene
uh yeah
you mentioned andy circus obviously i'm
a huge fan of andy um what do you think
what was it like you worked with him
previously on on apes what was it like
collaborating with him behind the scenes
in the making of this movie what did he
bring to the table that you really
respected or loved
well i mean what you want from your
director is that they're going to know
exactly what they're doing they're going
to be uh
extremely prepared and very professional
and the bonus was andy's a really good
friend of mine and i know
that if he says oh i like that take
don't worry we're moving on it's good
and i'm thinking is that okay you know i
trust him you know like i trust him
implicitly
and the trust pays off because i think
he made a wonderful movie uh i tell you
i think that guy is
i don't know what he can't do he can do
anything he's a relentlessly hard worker
and he's just absolutely brilliant
i have to stop there sir it is always a
pleasure to talk with you i wish you
nothing but the best
well hey it's a pleasure see we we
should do this more often
you mean the time in the place have a
great day man
all right buddy take care